[Applause]
with the first pick in the 2019 NBA
Draft the New Orleans pelicans select
Zion Williamson to start his
professional career and to really assume
the mantle then Anthony Davis leaves
behind after the trade can be the face
of the franchise in New Orleans shot 82
percent in transition the highest player
efficiency rating in the last 10 years
they've only been keeping that in for 10
years
higher than even it with the second pick
in the 2009 NBA Draft the Memphis
Grizzlies select job Moran
passer in the draft Johnson he's got
creativity delivery with either hand
he's an ambidextrous passer average ten
assists per game that led the nation
he's also really creative he doesn't
just see angles
he creates angles body control he can
[Applause]
with the dirt pick in the 2019 NBA Draft
the New York Knicks select RJ berry
man among freshmen all-time in division
1 history he really enjoyed the entire
process at newts that everybody needs
that year at college to play 4th night
go Waffle House in the wee hours ever
well he's got an NBA body right now with
the fourth pick in the 2009 NBA Draft
the Los Angeles Lakers select DeAndre
hunter from the University of Virginia
going against Jared Culver of Texas Tech
is going to be a lottery pick but
DeAndre hunter is the best individual
defender in this draft he's got a 72
wingspan he can guard 1 through 5 you'll
remember Tony Bennett put him on Carson
Edward
with the fifth pick in the 2019 NBA
Draft the Cleveland Cavaliers select
Darius garland from Vanderbilt
University
it was autographed by Chauncey Billups
is that right how about that because you
told me today because you've been high
on him and that's why we were testing
you and you said well I haven't met him
yet with the sixth pick in the 2019 NBA
Draft the Phoenix Suns select Jared
Culver from Texas Tech University
Olympic aspirations training for the
2020 Olympics faith is a big part of the
Culver family in this journey
Jared after saying hello to his
grandmother saying hello
with the seventh pick in the 2009 NBA
Draft the Chicago Bulls select Kobe
white from the University of North
Carolina Williams and I'm sure that
Donald whose